SEES SERVICES COMMITTEE WILL
COME TO ORDER. IN RESPONSE TO
THE CALL BUT NINETEEN.
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HUGE SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WHAT THE WHAT THOSE
ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO ONE OR TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SIX FIVE FOUR TWO EIGHT
NINE SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PROCESS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU ARE NOT READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR. YOU CLEARLY AND
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING. THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAKE
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
IN. ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING. SERVICE ARE
HAPPIER CONNECTIONS NEEDED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT A HEARING
TO CAN AS CLOSE TO THE SAME
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE
MAY BE SOME LACK TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS FOR JUSTIN TO THE
NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL PATIENTS ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS WE WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. ACCORDINGLY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WILL
BE LIMITED TO THREE MINUTES
EACH ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY DURING PUBLIC COMMENT
MUST LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURES. TODAY
WE HAVE ELEVEN BILLS ON THE
AGENDA. HOWEVER THE HEARING OF
SENATOR SCANNERS SB THREE FIVE
FOUR IS POSTPONED BY THE
COMMITTEE FOR BILLS AREN'T
CONSENT THOSE BILLS ARE SB ONE
HUNDRED. SB THREE NINE THREE SB
TWO TWO A AND E'S BEFORE SIXTY.
LET'S START WITH ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM I LIKE TO REMIND MEMBERS
TO TURN ON THEIR MICROPHONES
AND SPEAK INTO THE MICROPHONE
STRUCK THE HEARING. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HER TADO
HERE. JONES CORTESE. KAMLAGER
PAN THERE. WE HAVE A QUORUM.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM LET'S
CALL UP OUR FIRST AUTHOR TO
PRESENT THEIR FELT. AND FIRST
UP IS. SENATE BILL FOUR THREE
FOUR BY SENATOR BATES. SENATE
RATES UP PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY. FIVE
MILLION. YES THEY BEGIN YES. I
WAS DISTRACTED ANYWAY THANK YOU
ARE BETTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
LIKE SB FOUR THIRTY FOUR
PROHIBITS AN OPERATOR OF A
LICENSE RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
FACILITY OR CERTIFIED ALCOHOL
OR OTHER DRUG PROGRAM FROM
PROVIDING ANY FORM OF FALSE
ADVERTISING OR MARKETING
SERVICES MY NAME THIS BILL
BRANNON SAW AN HONOR OF BRANDON
NELSON WHO PASSED AWAY IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY SIX AND AN UNLICENSED
REHAB HOME HIS PARENTS WHO
SIGNED BRANDON UP FOR CARE AT
WHAT THEY BELIEVED. WAS A
TREATMENT FACILITY AND WE'RE
SURE THAT HE WOULD RECEIVE
THERAPY SESSIONS THE CASE
MANAGER A HOUSE MANAGER AND
MORE UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS NOT
WHAT HE RECEIVED ACCORDING TO A
COMPREHENSIVE INVESTIGATION BY
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA NEWS
GROUP IT FOUND AND I QUOTE
NELSON DIDN'T HAVE A TEAM OF
PROFESSIONALS OVERSEEING HIS
TRANSITION HE APPARENTLY DIDN'T
EVEN GET HIS MEDICATIONS ON
TIME. AND ACCORDING TO HIS
PARENTS AND POLICE REPORTS WHAT
HE THOUGHT WERE SALES PITCHES.
NOT HEALTH CARE ADVICE. M.
QUOTE I BELIEVE WE HAVE AN ALL.
AS ALLEGE TO MAKE SURE THAT NO
PERSON HAS TO GO THROUGH WITH
THEM WAT BRANDON AS FAMILY
WENT THROUGH. OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS THE LEGISLATURE
HAS RECOGNIZED THAT CONSUMERS
WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS
HAVE DISABLING CONDITIONS AND
THAT THESE CONSUMERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES ARE VERY VULNERABLE.
HOWEVER THERE ARE NO PROVISIONS
IN THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE TO CONTROL
UNETHICAL MARKETING PRACTICES
THAT PREY ON DISTRESSED
FAMILIES. OR INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE SEEKING TREATMENT AS A
RESULT OF PATIENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES CAN BE MISLED
MISDIRECTED MISDIAGNOSED BY AND
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS. THE GOAL
OF SB FOUR THIRTY FOUR IS
PROTECT INDIVIDUALS WITH
ADDICTION. AND ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE RECEIVING THE TREATMENT
THAT THEY ARE PROMISED
MARKETERS WHO KNOWINGLY AND
WILLFULLY MAKE MATERIAL FALSE
STATEMENTS. WHETHER IN
ADVERTISING OR BY DIRECT
COMMUNICATION WITH CURRENT OR
POTENTIAL PATIENTS. MUST BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE. S. FOUR
THIRTY FOUR OFF ALSO AUTHORIZES
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO INVESTIGATE
ALLEGATIONS. OF MISCONDUCT AND
IMPOSE SANCTIONS ULTIMATELY
THIS MEASURES SEEK TO PROTECT.
THOSE WHO ARE AT THEIR MOST
VULNERABLE AND SEEKING
TREATMENT. THE BILL SUPPORTED
BY THE CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS AND THE ADVOCATES
FOR RESPONSIBLE TREATMENT. HE
SIMILAR VERSION OF THIS BILL
PASSED THIS COMMITTEE IN TWENTY
NINETEEN BUT WAS VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR AT THAT TIME THE BILL
ADDRESSES THOSE CONCERNS. IT
PASSED OUT OF SENATE HEALTH ON
CONSENT AND SO I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF BRANDON'S LOST. IN
HERE BUT HERE I BELIEVE
TELECONFERENCING OF ROSEN ALLEN
NELSON THE PARENTS OF BRANDON.
WILL TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TODAY.
WE WILL NOW OPEN UP TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION LEADER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT WILL BE AND OPPOSITION
WILL BE LIMITED TO THREE
MINUTES EACH- THE FIRST WITNESS
CAN FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THIS IS ALAN
NELSON- AND THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES FOR TAKING AN INTEREST IN
OUR FAMILY'S TRAGEDY AND
INTRODUCING S. B. PORT THIRTY
FOUR BRANDON'S WALL. MY WIFE
ROSE AND I HAVE BEEN MARRIED
FOR THIRTY THREE YEARS OUR
YOUNGEST SON JUSTIN IS A CAL
GRAD TWENTY THREE YEARS OLD AND
LIVES WITH US IN SANTA MONICA
WORKING ON A MUSIC CAREER. OUR
MIDDLE SON TRENT ON HARVARD
GRAD LIVES IN BOSTON A WORKS
FOR A TECHNOLOGY COMPANY. OUR
OLDEST SON BRANDON IS TWENTY
NINE YEARS OLD A U. EIGHT EIGHT
AEROSPACE ENGINEERING GRAD AND
HAS LIVED IN HEAVEN FOR THE
PAST THREE YEARS IN FIFTEEN
DAYS. UNFORTUNATELY HE IS
UNABLE TO PROVIDE HIS IMMENSE
TALENTS TO THE WORLD. IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BRANDON HAD A PSYCHOTIC BREAK
IN WAS TAKEN IN ON A FIFTY ONE
FIFTY THAT WAS AN EXTENDED.
PRIOR TO THAT HE HAD BEEN
EMPLOYED IN THE AEROSPACE
INDUSTRY AND A CONTRIBUTING
MEMBER OF SOCIETY. ONCE
COMMITTED INTO THE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM ROSE AND I ASSUME
BRANDED WOULD BE WELL TAKEN
CARE UP. WE KNEW NOTHING ABOUT
THE MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM BUT
ASSUME THAT THERE WOULD BE
STRICT REGULATION AND OVERSIGHT
THAT WOULD PROVIDE CARD RAILS
FOR HIS TREATMENT. BRANDON'S
EXPERIENCE NOTHING COULD BE
FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH. BRANDON
WAS PASSED FROM FACILITY TO
FACILITY ENDING UP IN A FOR
PROFIT PROGRAM THAT REPRESENTED
TO US THAT THEY HAD
PROFESSIONAL PSYCHIATRISTS AND
COUNSELORS. INSTEAD THE BRANDED
ENDED UP IN A SOBER LIVING HOME
WITH NO INDIVIDUAL ATTENTION
BUT RATHER A GROUP SESSION RUN
BY AN UNLICENSED COUNSELOR HE
WAS NOT GIVEN IS NEEDED
MEDICATION PRESCRIBED BY THE
PRIOR NONPROFIT HOSPITAL SHE
WAS NOT MONITORED AS AND THEN
PROMISE. AND AT SEVEN FORTY
FIVE PM ON MARCH EIGHTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BRANDON HUNG HIMSELF
IN THE SOBER LIVING HOME FROM
AN EXPOSE FIRE SPRINKLER AND
ONE OF THE SOBER LIVING HOME
BEDROOMS. THE NINE ONE ONE CALL
IS CHILLING AND I WOULD LIKE TO
SUBMITTED INTO EVIDENCE. HOUSE
MANAGER OF THE SOBER LIVING
HOPE DID NOT KNOW THE ADDRESS
OF THAT HOUSE HE DID NOT KNOW
BRANDON'S NAME HE DID NOT KNOW
BRAND INSPIRED HISTORY ANY DOT
DID NOT KNOW HOW TO ADMINISTER
CPR. BRANDON'S EXPERIENCE ROSEN
I BELIEVE THE CALIFORNIA MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM SHOULD BE
REVIEWED FROM TOP TO BOTTOM.
AND WE HAVE SOME SUGGESTIONS
BASED ON WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN
BOTH NONPROFIT AND FOR PROFIT
FACILITIES. STRICT REGULATION
AND OVERSIGHT COULD HAVE
PREVENTED OUR FAMILY AND NO
DOUBT HUNDREDS OF OTHER
FAMILIES. FROM BEING SENTENCED
TO A LIFETIME OF GRIEF. IN THE
MEANTIME SB FOUR THIRTY FOUR IS
A STEP TOWARDS MAKING SURE. THE
FOR PROFIT FACILITIES RUN BY
UNSCRUPULOUS CHARLATANS PROVIDE
THE CARE OF THE BABY PROMOTE
AND ADVERTISE. I DO NOT JUST
MAKE EMPTY PROMISES TROLLING
FOR HUMAN ATM MACHINES WITH NO
REGARD FOR THE WELFARE. AS WAS
DONE WITH BRANDON. THANK YOU
AND IF I COULD KNOW HOW TO
SUBMIT THE NINE ONE ONE CALL
INTO TESTIMONY I'D APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU. AND WE WILL
FOR NOW FOR MARCH SECOND
WITNESS. ROSE NELSON. HELLO
THANK YOU SENATOR BAIT FOR
OFFERING SB FOUR THREE
FOREIGNERS FUNDS HONOR BRANDON
WOULD HAVE ADVOCATED FOR THIS
BILL SHOULDN'T HAVE SURVIVED
THESE RE HAVE RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITY SHOULD NOT
MARKET ADVERTISE OR PROMOTE
SERVICES THAT THEY DO NOT
PROVIDE TO THE MENTALLY ILL OR
THOSE WHO SUFFER FROM ADDICTION
THE SO CALLED REHAB FACILITIES
HAVE SLICK WEBSITES PROMISING
PROFESSIONAL HELP FROM
PSYCHIATRISTS PSYCHOLOGISTS AND
THERAPISTS AND CASE MANAGERS.
SO WHAT DOES THIS ALL MEAN TO A
CONSUMER LIKE YOU AND ME
IMAGINE YOU ARE A PARENT OF AN
INTELLIGENT PROMISING YOUNG MAN
UNFORTUNATELY HIS STRICKEN BY
MENTAL ILLNESS AT AGE TWENTY
SIX NO DRUGS NO ALCOHOL QUALITY
SHOULD HEAR THE PSYCHOTIC BREAK
BECOME SUICIDAL AND IS TAKEN ON
A FIFTY ONE FIFTY DUE TO LAWS
YOUR CHILD IS PASSED BY A
SOCIAL WORKER FROM A NONPROFIT
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL TO A FOR
PROFIT REHAB TREATMENT
FACILITY. YOU VALIDATE THE
SOCIAL WORKERS ADVISED BY
CHECKING OUT THE FACILITY'S
WEBSITE IT CLAIMS TO HAVE THE
PERFECT MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY FOR YOUNG ADULTS.
LIKE BRANDON AS A PARENT THE
AWFUL. OF MENTAL ILLNESS THE
FIRST TIME YOU THIS IS AN AFTER
RECALL. ALL THE RIGHT WE ARE AT
THE PARA ON THE WEBSITE. THE
PROGRAM PROVIDES A THERAPIST A
PSYCHIATRIST PSYCHOLOGIST DAILY
GROUP THERAPY AND MUCH NEEDED
MEDICATION WHICH WAS
PRESCRIBED. YOU THINK HOPE IS
ON THE WAY WRONG. HOW WOULD YOU
KNOW YOUR CHILD IS REALLY GOING
TO A HOUSE RENTED BY THE
TREATMENT FACILITY. THE HOUSE
IS LOCATED IN A RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOOD IT IS NOT LIKE AND
BECAUSE ONLY THE FACILITY
HEADQUARTERS THIS LICENSE. IN
THIS RESIDENTS HOUSE THERE ARE
PROGRAMS NO PROFESSIONAL
THERAPY NO PSYCHIATRIST NO
PRESCRIBED MEDICATION. AND NO
CONNECTION TO MUCH NEEDED
FAMILY MEMBERS YOUR CHILD IS
STRIPPED OF ITS BONE DRIVER'S
LICENSE. THAT'S PART OF THEIR
STAKE TREATMENT PLAN. IMAGINE
THIS HAPPEN TO YOU BECAUSE THIS
IS OUR SON STORY. OUR BELOVED
SON BRANDON HUNG HIMSELF IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND ON
LICENSE FOR PROFIT RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT HOUSE IN SAN CLEMENTE
CALIFORNIA WHEN FOUND HIS BODY
STILL WARM THE ON. LICENSE NON
PROFESSIONAL HOUSE MANAGER
CALLED NINE ONE ONE IN AN
EFFORT TO SAVE HIM. THE HOUSE
MANAGE YOUR GRANNY EVEN TELL
NINE ONE ONE WHAT THE ADDRESS
THEY WERE LOCATED WHAT HE
DIDN'T KNOW BRANDON'S NAME IS
AGE IT NOT ONLY PSYCHIATRIC
BACKGROUND HE DIDN'T KNOW CPR
IT WAS TOO LATE. OUR SON WAS
GONE TOO SOON. I PRAY THAT
ANOTHER FAMILY WILL NEVER
EXPERIENCE AN AWFUL TRAGEDY
LIKE ARE THE COMPANY OF
UNIMAGINABLE. THERE CAN BE A
SOLUTION SB FOUR THIRTY FOR
BRANDON'S LAW PROVISION OF
DEATHS THAT DECEPTIVE MARKETING
PRACTICES. MUST PASS AND RETAIN
YOU FOR YOUR AB. THANK YOU TO
OUR WITNESSES FOR- IT IS
SHOWING THE STORY OF YOUR SON
WITH US IT HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE TODAY AND AT THIS
MOMENT WILL GO HEAD AND TAKE
PUBLIC- COMMITTEE PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT WE'LL BEGIN
WITH ROOM FORTY TWO ZERO THREE.
THREE NINE ARE MOVING ON TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. FORTY THREE
NINE ARE WE WILL GO WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE AS A REMINDER TO THOSE
WHO ARE WAITING ON THE PHONE.
UP TO THE MINUTE TESTIMONY TO
NAME AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. OUR
MODERATOR PLEASE FUND
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR THREE
FOUR AND PROVIDE THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB. FORTY
FOUR. ABSOLUTELY THERE TO- THE
PURSUANCE FROM LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI YEAH BILL
WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. MODERATOR KEEP PLEASE
LET US KNOW HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS ARE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB. FOUR
THREE FOUR- THERE'S ON MORE
WE'RE GATHERING THEIR LINE
NUMBERS ONE MOMENT.
MODERATED
WE HAVE AN UPDATED CAN PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES AND CALL THE
SUPPORT WITNESSES INDIVIDUALLY.
YES ONE MOMENT.
OKAY NUMBER
TWENTY TWO LINES OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBER SHERRY
DAILY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF. CAN YOU HEAR ME.
WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW YES NOW.
SORRY THERE WAS A BIT OF A
DELAY SHERRY DAILY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. A MODERATED
Q. PLEASE A PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
AND LET US KNOW WHAT HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE WAITING IN THE QUEUE.
THEY CAN DETERMINE WHO WISH TO.
MAKE A COMMENT AND- ARE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
JUST A MOMENT.
AND THEN OTHERS
IN Q. HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOT FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION. ARE WE HAVE NO
KNOWN WITNESSES TO AT TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION WE WILL.
GO HEAD AND- OF TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION AND ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE SEEN NONE.
WE'LL BE LOOKING AT ROOM TWENTY
FORTY C. NINE. CAN NOW WILL BE
MOVING ON TO OUR TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT- FOR WITNESSES
WOULD TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE AS A
REMINDER TO THOSE FOR WHEN ON
THE PHONE PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TEST MUCH NAME AFFILIATION IN
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR THREE
FOUR. AND PROVIDE THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FOUR THREE FOUR. THE GENTLEMAN
WHO IS TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF US PEOPLE AT THREE FOUR. AM
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND CALL
THE OPPOSITION WHEN THIS
INDIVIDUAL WE WILL CONTINUE. AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
PARTICIPANT IN Q. THANK YOU.
ARE AT THIS MOMENT I WILL TAKE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SENATOR PAN.
YES SIR THANK THANK YOU I WOULD
FOR SIDE SO I THINK THE AUTHOR
CENTER BATES FOR PUTTING THIS
BILL FORD AND I KNOW THAT- YOU
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
HARD ON TRYING TO IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY IN
THIS AREA I KNOW WE'VE HAD A
FEW BUMPS IN THE ROAD IN TRYING
TO DO THAT- BUT I'VE ALWAYS
APPRECIATED- YOU ADVOCACY HERE
CERTAINLY THIS BILL WHICH WAS
HEARD AND VOTED ON UNANIMOUSLY
BUT HEALTH COMMITTEE OUT TO
PASS- I THINK IS AN EXCELLENT
STEP TOO AGAIN PROVING THAT
TRANSPARENCY NO WE'RE STILL
STRUGGLING WITH HOW TO DO IT ON
LICENSE BECAUSE WE ONLY HAVE.
PUT OUT LICENSORS AND WE THAT
LEVERAGE POINT- THERE BUT
CERTAINLY THIS ADDRESSES A I
THINK IMPORTANT ASPECT AND WITH
THAT- SOLELY WITH. THAT LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL TO PROTECT. THANK
YOU CENTER PANEL BE MOVING TO
OUR VICE CHAIR. SURVEYS I JUST
WANT TO KNOWLEDGE AND THINK
YOU'RE WITNESSES FOR. SHARING
THEIR STORY WITH US TODAY I
HAVE THREE CHILDREN IN THAT
SAME. AGE GROUP AND A SON THAT
WORKS IN THE AEROSPACE ENGINE
AT INDUSTRY AND- OCELOT STRUCK
A VERY PERSONAL TO ME. AND OUT
WE SUPPORTING THE BILL AS WELL-
REGARDING THE QUESTION OF. THE
RECORDING INTO INTO. DO YOU
HAVE A WAY OF COMMUNICATING
THAT TO ALL OF US ARE TO THE
NEXT COMMITTEE YEAR HOW WOULD
YOU LIKE TO HANDLE THE
RECORDING OF THE NINE ONE ONE
CALL. YOU WILL. HAVE A COPY OF
IT. I DON'T HAVE. A THE
PHILADELPHIA PA HOW WE YOU KNOW
DISTRIBUTE GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL USE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
THANK. TO OKAY SO WE HAVE A
MOTION THA- ON THE FLOOR AND
AT CENTER BASS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I JUST THINK YOU FOR
THE TIME AND THANK YOU FOR THE
ATTENTION TO THEIR PHONE I KNOW
DR PANDA ALL OF YOU'VE BEEN
VERY ON INVOLVED AND CERTAINLY
I HAVE STORIES ON YOUR OWN
DISTRICTS SO I THIS IS A
ANOTHER STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND WE HAVE TO KEEP
WORKING ON IT IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS I THINK THAT WE ALL
FEEL. PERSONALLY ABOUT XIN AND
CERTAINLY WE WANT TO PROTECT
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE THAT FOLKS
LIKE THIS WHO ARE YOU KNOW
ADVERTISING SOMETHING THAT
DOESN'T EXIST IN AND CAPTURING
PEOPLE BY THE WAY THEY DO WE
REALLY HAVE TO REIN THE MAN SO
HI I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR
IDOL AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES WE HAVE A MOTION ON S. B.
FOUR THREE FOUR BY CENTER BATES
AB. CONVO THINKING PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS HER
TADO. HI THE TITLE II JONES.
JONES BY CORTESE. KAMLAGER AYE
CAMARGO AYE PAN PANTAI. WE WILL
PLACE THIS BILL ON CALL TO
ALLOW OTHER MEMBERS. BEFORE I-
AT LAST THE BEFORE WE MOVE ON
TO AGENDA ITEM TO A ONE OF
RECOGNIZED ON OUR NEWEST MEMBER
OF OUR COMMITTEE AND NEAR
SENATOR OF THE SENATE FAMILY
THAT ARE COME LONGER WELCOME TO
THE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE AND WE'RE EXCITED TO
HAVE YOU HERE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU.
THANK YOU. HE SO MOVING ON TO
AGENDA ITEM TO WE HAVE SB SEVEN
SIX EIGHT BY SENATOR GLAZER.
LASER PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AT. I THANK THE
CHAIR INNER STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS BILL SB
A SEVEN SIX EIGHT. CLEANS UP A
MEASURE FROM LAST YEAR S. B.
TWELVE THIRTY TWO CLEANS UP IS
PROBABLY NOT THE RIGHT WORD
ENHANCES OR EXPANDS. THE
IMPORTANT POLICY PURPOSE OF SB
TWELVE THIRTY TWO WHICH ALLOWED
QUALIFYING LOW INCOME STUDENT
PARENTS. ENROLLED IN PUBLICLY
FUNDED COLLEGES- TO THAT WERE
WORKING PART OR FULL TIME TO
RECEIVE CAL WORKS BENEFITS FOR
UP TO FOUR YEARS. I ALSO
RECEIVE FUNDS TO PURCHASE BOOKS
PRIOR TO THE BEGINNING OF THE
ACADEMIC TERM. THIS BILL
EXPANDS TWELVE THIRTY TWO IN
THE FOLLOWING WAYS. NUMBER ONE
IT MAKES ELIGIBLE STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN PRIVATE FOR A NOT
FOR PROFIT INSTITUTIONS. NUMBER
TWO IT CLARIFIES THAT ALL
INSTRUCTIONAL HOURS INCLUDING
INCLUDE SUMMER SESSION CLASSES.
AND NUMBER THREE CLARIFIES THAT
THE STUDENTS ARE NOT SUBJECT TO
SELF INITIATED PROGRAM RULES. A
COLLEGE EDUCATION IS EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT TO ATTAIN FOR STUDENT
PARENTS. ON CAL WORKS. AND THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
ONLY EXACERBATED THOSE
STRUGGLES AS PARENTS ARE FORCED
TO JUGGLE WORKING ND STUDYING
FROM HOME WHILE STILL PROVIDING
CHILD CARE. STUDENT PARENTS ON
CAL WORKS ARE OFTEN REQUIRED TO
WORK AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY TO
THIRTY HOURS TO RECEIVE FULL
CAL WORKS OF BENEFITS. THE
STUDENT ON CAL WORKS TO DOT
MEET THEIR WORK OUR
REQUIREMENTS. THEY COULD HAVE
HAD THEIR BENEFITS REDUCED THIS
EFFECTIVELY PUNISHED LOW INCOME
PARENTS. WERE SEEKING A COLLEGE
EDUCATION. IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT
WE ENSURE ALL STUDENT PARENTS
INCLUDING THOSE IN PRIVATE NOT
FOR PROFIT INSTITUTIONS. HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO COMPLETE
THEIR COLLEGE EDUCATION BEFORE
THEIR ELIGIBILITY ON CAL WORKS
ENDS. SB SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT
ENSURES THAT THESE HARD WORKING
STUDENTS. THE SUPPORT NECESSARY
TO COMPLETE THEIR EDUCATION.
AND THE ANALYSIS THERE SOME
SUGGESTED COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WHICH I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT. WITH
ME TO TESTIFY TODAY. IS KEVIN
ASPLENIUM FROM THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION TO SPEAK FOR ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF HELPING OUR
CAL WORKS STUDENTS. BUT THAT
MANAGER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER WE WILL NOT OPEN IT
UP TO A DECISION SUPPORT
OPPOSITION NEED WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL BE
LIMITED TO THREE MINUTES EACH
AND ON THE CALL WE HAVE- OUR
WITNESS WAITING TO TESTIFY
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON-
THANK DOCTOR FOR THIS BILL-
SPECIALLY A. B. THE TWELVE
THIRTY TWO WE HAD A WEAPON ARE
FLOWN IN IT IN JANUARY TWENTY
FIFTH THERE WERE TWO HUNDRED
PEOPLE WHO ATTENDED THE WEAPON
UP FROM ACROSS THE STATE AND
THIS BILL WITH TRACKS- OF THE
GOVERNMENT SOME OF THE INITIAL
STEP TOWARDS. THAT AND THESE.
DURING THAT- DURING MEETING.
AND THEN MEANS BEEN THIS. THE
TECHNICAL BILL THAT CLEARED UP
MAKE SURE THAT IN THE END THE
MIDDLE. HOWEVER IT'S ALL OF THE.
BUT- HUMBLEST SOMETHING THAT
WILL MAKE. OTHER WILL YOU
DOCTOR ARE ISN'T CROSSES T. AND
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYTHING GOING
ALONG SMALL THAN I WOULD SHOULD
I FOR YOU. NOT GOT TO HAVE TO
ANSWER ANY. THAT YOU MAY. THANK
YOU I. WE WILL NOW ARE GOOD
PUBLIC OF AND WE'LL BEGIN WITH
ROOM FOR TO THE THREE. SEVEN
WILL MOVE ON TO ROUTE TWENTY
FORTY THREE NINE WE WILL MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. AS A REMINDER TO THOSE
WHO ARE WAITING ON THE PHONE
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
NAME AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL MODERATOR
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN SIX EIGHT AND
PROVIDE THE TOTALNUMBER F
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF SB. SEVEN SIX
EIGHT. RELATED AND- IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT AND- THE POINT OF SB
SEVEN SIX EIGHT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME THE COMPANY
THERE'S THREE IN Q. AS WE GO TO
LINE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO JASON SOMEONE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATE
PAYMENT PROGRAM SUBJUGATION AND
WORKS ORDER SB SEVEN SIX EIGHT
THANK YOU. JUST ONE MOMENT. WE
GO TO LINE AND TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK YES. YEAH. DO WE
HAVE A EIGHTY THREE YEAR THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES SERVING MORE THAN
THIRTY THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
ADULT LEARNERS AND
UNDERGRADUATE PROGRAMS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN SIX
EIGHT. WE GO TO LINE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CAN YOU IMAGINE CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK THE
TRUTH AND YOU'RE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE ARE
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. SEVEN SIX
EIGHT THANK YOU. WE GO TO LINE
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ANSWER HER TADO JARED CALL FROM
NOURISH CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO OTHER THAN Q. COOL.
THANK YOU HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE NO
KNOWN WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO TESTIFY- BUT WE WILL MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
WILL BEGIN WITH ROOM FORTY TWO
ZERO THREE. THE NUN WOHL ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. C. NINE WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE AS A
REMINDER TO THOSE WHO ARE
WAITING ON THE PHONE PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO NAME
AFFILIATION YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL. MODERATOR PLEASE PUMP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN SIX
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB.
SEVEN SIX EIGHT. DEMOCRATS IS
TO COME IN OPPOSITION- OF SB
SEVEN SIX EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. TENDER NO
PARTICIPANT IN Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR. ARE WE WILL MOVE TO
COMMENTED UNDER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SB SEVEN SIX
EIGHT. THREE NINE OKAY SENATOR
GLAZER WHICH I'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING STUDENT
PARENTS ON CAL WORKS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION AND MAKE A BETTER
LIFE FOR THEMSELVES AND WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. I'M OF THE WE HAVE A
MOTION ARE TO MOVE SENATE BILL.
SEVEN SIX EIGHT FOR SENATOR
GLAZER. CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SB SEVEN SIX EIGHT BY
GLAZER THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST DEMAND AND RE
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS HER
TADO I HAVE FURTADO I'D JONES.
JONES BY CORTESE. HOUSE COM
LOGGER HI KAMARG ARE AYE PAN.
OKAY WE WILL BE A PLACE THIS
BILL ON CALL UNTIL OTHER
MEMBERS TO VOTE ON THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZERS. WILL
BE NON WE HAVE UP NEXT S. B.
ONE ZERO EIGHT. THAT'S ME.
THREE HAVE AGENDA ITEM FOR S.
B. ONE OH EIGHT. BY TEAMCENTER
COMPARABLE THE GOOD AFTERNOON-
MEMBERS. IT HUNDRED INTRODUCED
SB ONE ZERO EIGHT- IN NINETEEN
FORTY EIGHT THE UNITED NATIONS
GENERAL ASSEMBLY ADOPTED THE
UNIVERSAL DECLARATION OF HUMAN
RIGHTS. ONE OF THEM INCLUDED
THE RIGHT TO ADEQUATE FOOD. IT
IS TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
DECLARE AND REAFFIRM ITS
COMMITMENT TO SECURING THIS
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT IT IS FOR
THIS REASON I AM INTRODUCING S.
B. ONE ZERO EIGHT. SB ONE ZERO
EIGHT DECLARES THAT THE
ESTABLISHED POLICY OF
CALIFORNIA THAT EVERY HUMAN
BEING HAS THE RIGHT TO ACCESS
EFFICIENT HELP YET AND
AFFORDABLE FOOD. PRIOR TO THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IT
WE HAD A FOOD INSECURITY WHICH
WAS FURTHER WORSENED BY BY THIS
PANDEMIC AND IT REALLY SHOWED
ARBEL THE BILL OUR
VULNERABILITIES VULNERABILITIES
AND OUR FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN THE
UNITED NATIONS FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE ORGANIZATION
ASSESSED AT JUST FIFTEEN CROP
PLANTS PROVIDE 90% OF THE
WORLD'S FOOD ENERGY INTAKE.
WITH THREE MAKING UP TWO THIRDS
OF THIS. DISEASE OUTBREAK CAN
IMPACT OUR GLOBAL SUPPLY CHAIN
AND SUFFERING COULD BE MUCH
WORSE CLIMATE CHANGE IS FURTHER
THREATENING OUR FOOD SUPPLY
CHANGE WITH BIO THREATS
DROUGHTS AND R. AND FURTHER
WEAKENING OR ACCESS TO ADEQUATE
FOOD. WITH THE GROWING
POPULATION AND LAND. USE
CHANGES OUR ABILITY TO KEEP
PACE AND FEED THE RESIDENTS OF
THE STATE'S WILL BE CHALLENGED
CALIFORNIA FEED THE STATE THE
NATION AND THE WORLD AND WE
MUST PREPARE FOR THESE
CHALLENGES AND IMPROVE OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM. SB ONE- IT
REQUIRES STATE AGENCIES TO
CONSIDER HIM A RIGHT TO FOOD AS
THEY CREATE AMEND OR ADOPT
REGULATIONS BUT IT ALSO
REQUIRES A REPORT ON THE
CURRENT AND FUTURE STATUS OF
FOOD. FOOD PRODUCTION AND FOOD
ASSISTANCE. WE MUST MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE IN OUR STATE ARE
FOR NOW AND IN THE FUTURE. THIS
BILL WORKS TOWARDS THAT. AND
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I
HAVE. DAVID GUESS WHAT THE
BREAD OF THE WORLD. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES. OKAY THANK
YOU I AM DOING TO GET THEM
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF BREAD
FOR THE WORLD OUR NETWORK
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE CHURCHES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND OVER TWO
THOUSAND PASTORS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS IN CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
UNITED IN CALLING FOR A RIGHT.
TO DO THAT. WHEN WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THE HEALTH AND AMERICA'S
FOSTER THAT HONDA PANDEMIC.
WHEN WE UNDERSTAND HUNGER AND
FOOD INSECURITY AS PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUES. IN SECURING A
RIGHT TO ACCESS SUFFICIENT
AFFORDABLE AND HEALTHY FOOD
WITH DIGNITY BECOMES A MORAL
AND ECONOMIC IMPERATIVE FOR THE
STATE. PREPEND I CONFERENCE
COULD SECURITY COSTS THE US
ECONOMY OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY BILLION DOLLARS IN POOR
HEALTH OUTCOMES AN ADDITIONAL
HEALTHCARE AND I WAS PRE
PLANNED TO MAKE. A CALL
CALIFORNIA LOST A MILLION AND A
HALF JOB TO THE PANDEMIC AND
HUNGRIEST SPIKED IN MANY
COMMUNITIES. FOR EXAMPLE
INCLUDE BANKING ALAMEDA USED TO
SERVE FIFTY TO SIXTY FAMILIES
TODAY PRETTY PANDEMIC. REACHED
THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY TO
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FAMILIES A DAY DURING THE
SUMMER. ONE HUNDRED WAS HIGHER
WITH KIDS OUT OF SCHOOL. SO
BOTTOM LINE IS A STUDENTS
SECURITY AT A- NUMBER
CALIFORNIANS FAR TOO MANY.
CHILDREN CALIFORNIANS NEED THE
STATE TO SET THE STANDARD OF
LIVING RIGHT TO. AND SENATE
BILL OH EIGHT FACILITATES OUR
STATE BECOMING HEALTHIER AND
MORE ROBUST ECONOMICALLY IN THE
MONTHS AND YEARS TO COME AS WE
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC.
THANK YOU FOR IN THAT TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR THE NEXT
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. YOU
SOMEONE. OKAY WILL GO TO
WITNESSES IN- FORTY TWO OR
THREE- DOESN'T LOOK LIKE WE
HAVE ANYBODY HERE IN TWENTY
FORTY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NINE
THEIR- MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. KEVIN
ADMITTED COLUSA CALIFORNIA
WELFARE RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. AND THE
FIRST TO GO TO LINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE CENTERS ON
BEHALF OF S. T. I. U.
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF
OF THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT WE
GO TO LINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED
CALL NEAREST CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR THE TIME FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KELLY BROOKS
ON THE HALF OF THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
HERE IN SUPPORT. THAT COULD GO
TO LINE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON AND DELAY
SOCIAL BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER THEN WITH THE PORT
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON DEREK POLKA WITH
THE LOS ANGELES REGIONAL FOOD
BANK IN THE PARK THANK. THAT
COULD GO TO LINE FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH HI EVERYONE
BUT I THOUGHT THE GUY WITH THE
SENATE COMPROMISSO WE SUPPORT
SB FOUR SIX FOUR FOOTBALL
INJURY. OUR YEAH WE'RE ON SB
ONE AWAIT RIGHT NOW. MODERATE
IF YOU CAN REMIND THE CALLERS
THAT WERE ON SB ONE AWAY IN
SUPPORT. ABSOLUTELY DAVID
DENMAN- THIS IS FOR SUPPORT OF
S. B. ONE OH EIGHT- NEXEO TWO
LINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER ADDRESS ON BEHALF OF
NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA'S THE COURT.
NEXT WE GO TO LINE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN Q. ALL
RIGHT MR MURRAY IF YOU CAN ASK
ONE MORE TIME IF THERE'S ANY-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ONE AWAITS. COOLEY GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF SB ONE OH EIGHT. PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY KEY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I
DON'T THINK THERE ARE- WILL GO
TO FORTY TWO OR THREE. NOBODY
IN FOR TWO OR THREE IN TWENTY
FORTY. NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
MISTER MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO S.
B. ONE OH EIGHT ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. HE'S A
DUMB ISSUE WHICH TO COMMON IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ONE OH EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO IT'S
TIME. BUT AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO OTHERS IN Q. THANK YOU
AS MODERATOR WILL TAKE IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS CONCERNS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. DR PAN MOVES THE
BILL NO OTHER COMMENTS. WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SB ONE AWAIT BY HER TADO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES HER TADO. NINE FOR TOTAL
AYE JONES SOMEBODY. JONES NOT
VOTING CORTESE HI. PARTE CI
CALM WATER HI COME LONGER
ONLINE PAN I. CAN BY. THAT'S
FOUR ZERO THAT VOTE HAS THAT
DOES FOUR ZERO I THINK THAT'S
EVERYBODY RIGHT. SO WE CAN MOVE
ON TO OR DID YOU WANT TO BE
DOING YEARS NEXT REGION I GOT
ONE RUBIO. I HAVE BEEN WORKING
OKAY LET ME LET SOMEBODY ELSE
CHAIR OF I APOLOGIZE I HAVE TO-
TIME IS SCHEDULED. FIFTEEN
MINUTES SO I DO WANNA LET. OKAY
SORRY. YES I'LL SAY THAT THE
BILL IS OUT. SORRY YOU. OKAY
LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX SIXTY FOUR SIXTY
FOUR BY CENTER HURTADO
CERTAINLY WOULD YOU LIKE BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS BOSTON
HERE TO PRESENT SB FOUR SIX
FOUR SB FOUR SIX FOUR ALSO
ADDRESSES FEEDING THE RESIDENTS
OF OUR STATE IT WORKS TO ENSURE
THERE IS GREATER EQUITY IN
CALIFORNIA'S FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS PRIOR TO THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC APPROXIMATELY
ONE IN TEN CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCE FOOD INSECURITY. THE
PANDEMIC AND RESULTING ECONOMIC
CRISIS HAS EXACERBATED FOOD
INSECURITY ACROSS THE STATE.
THE PARTICULARLY AMONG LOW WAGE
IMMIGRANTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS DACA
RECIPIENTS TEMPORARY PROTECTED
STATUS HOLDERS AND CERTAIN VISA
HOLDERS ARE EXCLUDED FROM
FEDERAL CALFRESH AND ARE STATE
FUNDED HEALTH CALIFORNIA FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THESE
EXCLUSIONS FORCED IMMIGRANT
HOUSEHOLDS TO MAKE IMPOSSIBLE
CHOICES BETWEEN BUYING
GROCERIES AND COVERING THE COST
OF RENT OR OTHER BASIC NEEDS.
THIS LIMITS OUR ABILITY TO
ACHIEVE ECONOMIC SECURITY AND
UPWARD MOBILITY. SB FOUR SIX
FOUR MODERNIZES THE CALIFORNIA
FOOD ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY FOR STATE
FUNDED NUTRITION BENEFITS TO
ANYONE IN ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH
TO SOLELY THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS. IN DOING SO THE BILL
PROVIDES GREATER FOOD SECURITY
TOO LOW INCOME AND IMMIGRANT
WORKERS HELPING LIFT THEM OUT
OF POVERTY AS CATFISH IS PROVEN
TO DO. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT I HAVE POSSIBILITIES TO
DEAL WITH NOURISH CALIFORNIA
ANILINGUS ALEXIA WORKING MOTHER
LIVING IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WHO WOULD BENEFIT FROM THE
PROGRAM EXTENSION ENVISIONED IN
THIS BILL. RIGHT THANK YOU
CENTER TIDO UM WE WILL ALLOW
EACH. WITNESS UP TO THREE
MINUTES- SO LET'S GET AGAIN
BEGAN TO START WITH THE
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT- SO
MODERATE COMPLETE PLEASE BRING
ON THE LINE OUR LEAD WITNESSES.
TO TESTIFY. THAT'S A BILL AS
TO. AS TO DEAL AND- HURLING
SELECTOR SCEA SO WE CAN FIRST-
BRING AND- THAT'S BILL IS THE
DEAL- FIRST. IS A WITNESS ON
THE LINE YET. YES I AM CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES I CAN YES PLEASE
BEGIN. GREAT GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU CHAIR- WITHOUT ON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- MY
NAME IS AT SEVEN AT THE VIDEO
AND I'M ASKING ADVOCATE WITH
MARRIAGE CALIFORNIA- I WANTED
TO START BY THINKING CHAIR
PRESIDENT DONALD BARKER
DEALERSHIP ON THE PLASTIC OR-
KNOWN AS THE BLUE CARABELLO-
THIS BILL WILL REDUCE HUNGER
AND POVERTY BY ENSURING THAT.
EIGHT MAGICIAN- BUT NOT THAT
CAN ON BASIS OF IMMIGRANTS
STATUS. I THINK WE ALL. BEING
AND- THIS. AND THAT MAKE IT THE
HARSH ACROSS STATE.
PARTICULARLY AMONG LOW WAGE
THEN ONE AND FAMILIES. MANY
WORKERS FRESCO NINETY EXPO TO
GROW OUR BEST IN CLASS THE FOOD
HE THOUGHT BASE. THE NATION AND
THE WORLD. GET THEIR WAGES ARE
STILL LOW PERHAPS TO GO HE
BECAUSE OF COMMON. ELEMENT THAT
THEY STRUGGLED A PER COULD
PRONOUNCE. UCLA RITA AT THAT
COMPOSER SIX OF. I'M SURE WAS
INCLUDING OVER ONE TWO MIL
BUCKS CAL. WORKING FRONT JOB.
MAKING NINETY EXPO EVERYTHING
OKAY FOR LOW WAGE. THIS WORKING
AT OF AND HELPING US WITH THAT
BUT ON THE TABLE. UNDOCUMENTED
AND MANY EMERGING TALENT. ARE
INGESTING. CALTRAIN CAL COULD
PROGRAM AND OTHER OF THAT. AN
ESTIMATED ONE IN THREE AND-
PRESS IN THE PATH AND NINETY
PER OF THE CURRENT THEY'VE WITH
U. S. FOREIGN POTENTIAL. I
CURRENT CALPERS POLICY MAKES
PARENTS INVEST. ONLY EVEN IN
PARENTS WITH THE RIGHT OF
PRODUCTS. INCLUSIONARY DENIED
COMMUNITIES THE POD PALA AND I
CAN AND IT. OF CALVET OKAY.
DEEPENING THIRTY BASED ON RACE
DECLINE. HE RECORDED AND LATER
STUDIES THAT SHOW THAT ACCESS
NOW- OR CAN I THAT KNOW IN OUR
STATE CAL IMPROVE. OVERALL HOW
OUTCOME OF LOW INCOME BUT THAT
CAN FIT IN CAR OVER THE LONG.
RESEARCH STUDY- ALSO SHOW
SHOULD WHO WITH SNAP CALFRESH
BETTER. WHICH IS THEIR LAW TERM
AND OUTCOMES. SO AN INVESTMENT
IN COULD HAVE. ALL IMMIGRANT
HOW OLD PRIDE OUR ECONOMY AND
HELPED BY CRIED ANNIKA DOWN BY
THE ONE WAY IN RIGHT NOW. SO
HOW CAN THAT BE SO WE HAVE
ASKED QUEST FOR. THAT SEEKS TO
MY THE K. COULD. OF THEM- AS
MANY. OF US KNOWING FEEDBACK-
THE COULD NOT MODERN OUR SPEECH
AT INFRASTRUCTURE. TO PROVIDE
STATE FUNDED BY. ALL CAL. WHO
ARE NOT ELIGIBLE ACCOUNT. OR
THAT YOU THE IMMIGRATION.
EMINENTLY THAT A THE LONG
STANDING ISSUE OF TO AN
AMERICAN. AND ATTRACT THE WAY
THAN THE FROM OUR STATE INCOME.
ONE CLOSING I. THIS IS THE FOR
CALIFORNIA CHAMPION VOEPEL LIKE
SB FOUR SIX FOUR ONE POINT
FORTY DIFFERENT BATES. ARE
NATION ALL CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF THAT MAKE STATUS.
I'M THAT COULD BE. WHEN I WHEN
I THOUGHT OF IT. RIGHT PLEASE
BEGIN WELCOME. THANK YOU A ONE
I THOUGHT OF ANOTHER I WOULD
PROBABLY MEAN OF THE LOCAL THAT
NUMBER IS. ELEVEN YEAH THE BY
MEMBER ABOUT ABOUT THE THAT THE
ARE VIOLATE MAKING ENDS IN
THEIR AGE COOLEY BUDDY GOING ON
TO THE GOVERNMENT. ONE THEY
AGAINST THE- WILL BUY YET THE
NEAR I KNOW THE- NFL OF THE
BAND. AND ON SUNDAY KILEY.
GETTING A MOMENT ALL THAT
MATTERS YOU DON'T WITH IN WE DO
BEAT THE MARKET BOB- ITSELF OF
PEOPLE I HOPE. NO MORE THAN ONE
OR TWO AND PEOPLE TO GARY I OF
THE GET GET THE UPPER LEVEL IT
COMES. HE THERE'S A MOMENTO
DIJO OF THAT OUR HUMBLE. I CAN
I CAN TRANSLATE INTO BIGGER ON
BOEING YOU KNOWONE. THE BIG
OTHER POPULAR LUCAS BEING A
HAVE GONNA BEEN OUR THING ABOUT
A PER ON THIRTY. PAGE BUT THE
MINNESOTA MY BOARD THE ONE GOAL
AND PRESIDENTE TRONG FOR THE
MEDICAL METAL GOING ON BUT THE
OTHER DAY. BIG K. HEY LOOK I
GOT BECAUSE OF THAT I MEAN. IF
THE CODE I'M LEVEL THE
IMPOSSIBLE I YOU A LOOK AT
EVERYTHING ON THE BUT YET THE
WOMEN MANTLE UNIVERSITY NUMBER
THAT I OF THE BALL. IF I
THOUGHT SAM FAMILIAR THOUGHT OF
THE SOME OF THE YEAH MUSLIMS.
ALSO THIS BILL WILL MAN. THE
BOOK BUT I WHEN I. IT GOES MAN
NOTICED REAL VIABLE IS THE
PRIMARY HOLDER ABOUT BUCKET BY
MICHAEL. CORBETT.
SACRAMENTO
AND I MEAN NOTHING WILL GET OUT
THEY MAKE THE MONEY THE
MILITANT GROUP THAT. MEDICAL
MONEY NOT BEING WITH THEM
BUCKLEY MEANING OF THE GOAL
WILL BE TO LOOK ON MY- WORK AT
THE MOMENT THERE'S BEEN
COMMENT. YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED A LONG LIFE THE
REQUESTED IF THE COURTS DON'T.
YEAH THE AMATEUR FOR ME LET.
COULD BE AN BUT AND THEY HAVE
BOTH MADE UP THE AUDIO. BEGIN
BY. CHANDANA BE GOING UP IN THE
NEAR THE LAKE- IS THAT BY EVEN
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT FOR WHAT
OPERATING AT. FORGET THEY MAY
YET ON MENTAL I TOLD. WILL NOT
VALUED TO GET. HANDLE TO SCHOOL
OKAY NO OKAY IS THAT BY THAT
THAT I AM NOT GOING ROOM AND
I'M GONNA IT AFTER. THE
EMPLOYER GOOD JUDGMENT YEAH.
THANK YOU VENTERS. DID SAID.
WOULD TO. YEAH FOR A
TRANSLATION NINETY. SHE'S SHE
IS AMONG OF THREE FROM THE SAID
OF LENDS CAME FROM COUNTRY
BONTA FACT THE EIGHT HER LIFE
WAS AT RISK THERE. DO NOT HER
HUSBAND LIVED IN THE CITY WILL
SEND. BUT SHE CAME THE
RECESSION SO THEY DO. TO THIS
OF LYNN BECAUSE- THEY WERE TOLD
THAT THERE WAS OF JOBS IN
AGRICULTURE. THEY DID WORK IN
AGRICULTURE AND THEY ARE
WORKING GROUP'S- THEY WERE ALSO
THEY'VE BEEN LIVING THROUGH
VERY DIFFICULT TIMES GIVEN
THAT- IF YOU TRUMP AN
IMMIGRATION- AND- SHE SAID HER
HUSBAND BECAME VERY SICK DUE TO
COLD BRED OUT WAS. HOME FOR AT
LEAST A MONTH AND I DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH. ENOUGH MONEY TO MAKE
ENDS MEET TO PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
FOOD FOR THEIR FAMILY. SHE HAS
A SEVEN YEAR OLD AND SHE WERE
RECALLED ONE NIGHT WHEN HER
DAUGHTER ASKED HER- FOR FOOD
SHE WAS REALLY HUNGRY AND SHE
DIDN'T WANT TO DO SHOES- AND
DIDN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO PROVIDE
FOR HER DAUGHTER HER DAUGHTER
CIVIL YOU KNOW CAN YOU GIVE ME
AT LEAST SOME MILK BUT SHE
HADN'T SO SHE ENDED UP HAVING
TO GO TO BED THAT EVENING. WITH
NINETEEN TO EAT AND SHE HOPES
THAT ARE WE CAN. PUSH IT PAST
SOMETHING THAT WILL HELP
FAMILIES LIKE HER AND MANY.
MORE ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVEN'T HAD.
ACCESS TO THOSE TYPES OF
BENEFITS THAT WOULD ALLOW
DURING DIFFICULT ECONOMIC TIMES.
THANK YOU AND AGAIN WANT TO
THANK BOTH OF OUR WITNESSES FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WE'RE NOW GOING
TO MOVE ON TO OTHER WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT. FOR THIS IT SAID
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL WHICH IS SB FOUR
SIXTY FOUR WILL BEGIN IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE SAYING NO
WITNESSES IN ROOM FORTY TWO. OH
THREE LET'S MOVE ON TO ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY SEEN NO INSTAGRAM
TWENTY FORTY LET'S MOVE ON TO
OUR TELEPHONIC LINE- MODERATOR.
Q. PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
SIXTY FOUR. AND AGAIN THAT'S
TESTAMENT YES THIRTY SEVEN HAVE
BEEN COLUSA CALIFORNIA WILL
PROVIDE CERTAIN TRANSITION
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. DON'T YOU
WISH TO- COME IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BEFORE SIX OR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. OF COURSE
WE GO TO LINE FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS TYPICALLY XABI OAK ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
SIGNED. NEXT WE GO TO LINE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MEMBERS CONSIDER SUCH
AS A LESSER IN ARMAGH POVERTY
WILL. THANK YOU NEXT TIME. LIKE
TO GO TO LINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WILL IT BE
CENTERS ON BEHALF OF S. E. I.
U. CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF. THANK YOU THANKS LINE.
MEXICO LINE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ANDREW CALLING FROM THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT TIME.
THANKS TO THE KLEIN FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ANDREA TERRY
REPRESENTING NO KID HUNGRY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU EXLINE.
LINE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI DAVID ON EXACTLY THAT
WOULD BE GONNA COMPROMISSO AND
WE SUPPORT FOOTBALL IMMIGRANTS.
THANK YOU NEXT. ONE THANKS WE
GO TO LINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS S. NINE
VARIANT FROM UC SAN DIEGO HEATH
ADVISORY COUNCIL AND SUPPORT AT
THE BELL. THANK YOU NEXT. ONE
MEXICO TO LINE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EVENTUALLY
WITH CALIFORNIA I AM- CALLING
TO REACH BUT ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS. HAVE
BREAD FOR THE WORLD. CALGARY
FOOD BANK CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS.
HUNGER ACTION LOS ANGELES
ALLIANCE SAN DIEGO. VETERANS
COMMUNITY SERVICES. CALIFORNIA
FEUD AND FARMING NETWORK.
SPRINGS CHARTER SCHOOL OPEN
HEART KITCHEN EVERYONE HARVESTS.
WELL ECONOMIC ENTERPRISES OF
LOS ANGELES. BLIGHTED AND YOUR
HUNGER COALITION CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURE NETWORK.
FRIENDS OF THE EARTH.
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. GOOD FOR
THE PEOPLE THAT MAKE IT
POSSIBLE COUNTY. SAN DIEGO.
THANK YOU KNOW COALITION FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA. RABAL
BEGINNINGS THANK YOU THANK YOU
T. ANYMORE SUPPORT CENTERED OUT
OF CAPEX LINE. THANKS TO THE
TIMELINE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SH KELLY BROOKS ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA HERE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT TIME.
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME LINE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS BENJAMIN CHILD
FROM THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. FROM THE SIX
WHO FROM HOME GOODS THANK YOU
THANKS LINE. MEXICO TO LINE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN COOL. THIS IS DEREK BUCKLE
AT THE LOS ANGELES REGIONAL
FOOD BANK IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
SIGNED. THANKS FOR YOUR TWO
LINES THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS THE
NUMBER THAT I'M IN THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
AT THE POINT THANK YOU FOR
CALLING. THANK YOU THANK A
MODERATE CHANGES TO INDICATE
HOW MANY MORE PEOPLE ON THE
LINE. WAITING CERTAINLY COUNTY
WOMAN. HE. WE HAVE- TEN MORE
RIGHT OKAY LET'S GO ON AN X.
THAT'S- EXLINE. TO GO TO LINE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS MADE UP AND I
HEAR WE'VE LIMON AT THE NOTHING
I DON'T BERNIE AMERICA AND
WEARING STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY COURT COULD FALL IN THE
GRANT. THANK YOU NEXT TIME.
LIKE TO GO TO LINE FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON AMY
JANE CANS ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT TIME. THANKS TO GO TO
LINE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I NEED A GRANT FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION COLLABORATIVE AND
STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB FORCED A
CORD FOR ALL IMMIGRANTS I THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK SIGN.
MEXICO TO LINE FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JASON FROM AROUND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATE PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION AND MORE
PRODUCTS FOR THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT TIME. THE NEXT TO GO
TO NINE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS RICARDO
LARA'S THE FROM THE URBAN AND
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY INSTITUTE
AT OCCIDENTAL COLLEGE AND THAT
WE ARE IN CONCORD SB FOUR SIX
FOUR GOOD FOR ALL IMMIGRANTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS LINE.
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME LINE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. KELLY GAME
WITH HEALTH NET IN CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND WELLNESS SERVING
ALMOST TWO MILLION BUT I CAL
MEMBERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT AS BEFORE THE COURT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
MEXICO TO LINE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
PETER PAN AM TWO ONE ON BEHALF
ALAMEDA COUNTY COMMUNITY FOOD
BANK STRONG SUPPORTER SB FORTY
FOUR IN A WEEK THANK AND HER
DAUGHTER THANK YOU EXLINE.
MEXICO TIMELINE SEVENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WELL I'M DEFINITELY
MUST ADDRESS OPEN THE NATIONAL
HEALTH FOUNDATION AND WE'RE
STRONG SUPPORTER SB SIX FORTY
SIX OR FORTY FOUR THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. BACK NEXEO TWO NINE
SEVENTY TWO I HAD. HI MY NAME
IS CHARITY EVENT WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION AND WE
ARE IN STRONG WHAT ABOUT THE
FOUR SIX FOUR THANK YOU NEXT
TIME. THANKS GO TO LINE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS NOT ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN COULD BENEFIT
INFORMATION. FOR THE FOR THE
WELL. THANK YOU NEXT. SEVENTY I
HAVE ONE MORE- THE DEADLINE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL I MEAN NUMBER THIRTY COME
IN I'M ON THE SIDE OF THE BALL
YOU NEED US FOR MAINLINE YEP WE
ARE NOT PROPOSED HIM QUICKLY
CUENTA. HI CRUSH. THANK YOU.
RIGHT ANYONE ELSE ON LINE. FOR
THE THUNDER NORTHERN IN Q.
THANKS VERY MUCH NOW LET'S MOVE
ON TO THE OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR
SIXTY FOUR- THERE'S NO FORMAL
OPPOSITION HAS BEEN REGISTERED
FOR TESTIMONY SO LET'S NOW MOVE
TO- FROM FORTY TO THREE SEEN ON
ROOM FORTY TWO A THREE LET'S
MOVE TO RUN TWENTY FORTY SEEN
NO ONE ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR. AT
WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR SIXTY
FOUR- NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. OF PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES MODERATOR. ABSOLUTELY IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF US BEFORE SIX OR- YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME.
MODERATOR'S ANYONE ON THE LINE.
WE ARE FOR YOUR LOVE LOCAL
GOING GLOBAL BANKRUPT. ALL
RIGHT I WASN'T SURE THAT WAS
TESTIMONY. WHAT I THINK IS FOR
ALL RIGHT BUT THERE'S ANYONE ON
THE LINE AND TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP FOUR SIXTY
FOUR. TO END OF TIME OR NO NO
ONE IN Q. RIGHT. THANKS VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT AND NOW LET'S
MOVE ON TO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES
ANNOUNCER COME UNDER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I JUST WANTED TO
KNOW IF YOU COULD TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WANT WHERE THE
FUNDING IS GOING TO COME FROM
FOR THIS. YES SENATE ON THE
BANK YOU THAT THAT. IS
SOMETHING THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK THROUGH ALONG THE PROCESS-
BUT IT'S A IT'S A- WE'RE HOPING
THAT THAT SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDED BE AVAILABLE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM. YEAH
PROBABLY AT TIMES THANK YOU I'D
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE- I JUST WANTED THAT
THANK YOU US ARE TOUGH FOR
BEING THIS BILL FORWARD I KNOW
THAT- IN DIFFERENT POSITIONS
PROCESS AND PERHAPS EVEN IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS HOPEFULLY TRY TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE FUNDING
ISSUES. BUT I THINK IN TERMS OF
POLICY THIS IS AN EXCELLENT
POLICY- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NAY VOTE ON- COMING UP OUT
OF THE LOS. THANK THANK YOU
CENTER TIDO SO THE- MOTION HAS
MADE BY SIR COME LONGER IS- DO
PASSED THE FIRST RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB FOUR SIX FOR HER TADO. HI
PORTATO ARE JONES. CORTESE ALL
RIGHT PORTE'S III COM LONGER I.
KAMLAGER I PAN HI ANNA HI THE
BILL CURRENTLY HAS FOUR VOTES
SO WE'LL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
AND HOW FAST WE DOUBLE BACK TO
YOU THAT'S IN PART OF. OKAY AND
WE WILL BE CALLING UP OUR
SENATOR RUBIO 2% ON SB SIX
SEVEN EIGHT THIS AND RUBIO-
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. TODAY I PRESENT
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY EIGHT
WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT BILL THAT
WILL MAKE CALIFORNIA THE FIRST
STATE IN THE NATION TO FOCUS ON
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THIS
GROUP AS DEFINED BY FEDERAL
RULES AS SINGLE WOMEN WITHOUT
CHILDREN OR DEPENDENTS. DESPITE
MAKING UP NEARLY ONE THIRD OF
HOMELESS ADULTS NATIONWIDE
THERE ARE NO PROGRAMS THAT
FOCUS ON THEIR NEEDS AND
EXPERIENCES ACCORDING TO
FEDERAL DATA ON UNACCOMPANIED
WOMEN EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
WEIGHTED AVERAGE OF TEN YEARS.
TO HAVE ACCESS TO STABLE
HOUSING IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT 80% OF THE EARTH OF THIS
GROUP REPORTED TRAUMA OR ABUSED
BY AN INTIMATE PARTNER. AS THE
COST OF THEIR HOMELESSNESS SO
WHEN PEOPLE ASK WHY DIDN'T SHE
LEAVE BASIS HI FOR THE ANSWER.
EITHER CONTINUE TO GET ABUSED
OR POSSIBLY END UP HOMELESS SO
IT'S NOT AN EASY CHOICE FOR
WOMEN THE FIRST STEP TO SOLVING
OUR HOMELESS PROBLEM IS HAVING
ACCURATE DATA. ABOUT WHO IS ON
HEALTH AND WHAT THEIR NEEDS
ARE. AND THIS BILL DOES EXACTLY
THAT SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT WILL
REQUIRE THE STATE'S HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCIAL
COUNSEL TO COLLECT DATA ABOUT
THIS GROUP FROM LOCAL CONTINUUM
OF CARE. AND USES DATA TO HELP
SET SPECIFIC MEASURABLE GOALS
TO PREVENT AND END
HOMELESSNESS. FOR THIS
FORGOTTEN GROUP OF WOMEN.
FINALLY THIS BILL COMPLIMENTS A
RECENT AUDIT OF THE HOMELESS
COORDINATED AND FINANCIAL
COUNCIL THAT STATES THAT THE
COUNCIL COULD BE MORE STRATEGIC
AND MORE DATA DRIVEN. IN THEIR
APPROACH TO SOLVING THE
HOMELESS CRISIS THE SPONSORS IS
DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S CENTER A
HOMELESS SERVICE PROVIDER
LOCATED AT LOS ANGELES SKID
ROW. IT IS SUPPORTED BY A WIDE
COALITION OF OVER TWENTY
HOMELESS PROVIDERS AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND IT
HAS NO OPPOSITION. IF I MAY I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY- MY
WITNESSES FIRST WE HAVE VICKY
VICKERS A FORMER UNACCOMPANIED
WOMEN EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
AND DR SOPHIA HERRERA THE
DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH PLANNING
AND POLICY AT THE HUB FOR URBAN
INITIATIVES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE WILL NOT OPEN IT UP TO
ASSIST IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION THE WITNESS AND
SUPPORT OPPOSITION BE LIMITED
TO THREE MINUTES EACH. LEAD
SUPPORT WHEN THIS NUMBER ONE
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR. MY NAME IS
VICKY BAKER AND I'M A PURE
LEADER WITH PROJECT ONE HUNDRED
IN ALLEYS GET BRO AT THE
DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S CENTER. I MEAN
I THINK THEY GET AROUND HOW
WOMEN. I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK
YOU TO SUPPORT SB SIX SEVEN
EIGHT. UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN
EXPERIENCE HOMELESS THAT ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. I BELIEVE IN
THIS BILL SO STRONGLY BECAUSE
WOMEN NEED TO BE RECOGNIZED TO
BE CARED. FOR IN TO BE SEEN FOR
THE FOUR PEOPLE THAT THEY ARE.
I MYSELF HOMELESS DUE TO GET.
WHICH I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH AT
THE AGE OF TWENTY. WHEN I RAN
OUT OF MEDICATION I HAD SEVERE
HALLUCINATIONS. I ENDED UP
LEAVING EVERYTHING AND WOUND UP
LIVING BEHIND AN OLD PARK IN
SANTA MONICA. I WAS THERE FOR
FOUR AND A HALF YEARS. LOCAL
POLICE WOULD REGULARLY PASS BY
THE PARK BUT BECAUSE I WASN'T
CAUSING ANY ISSUE. IT SEEMS. AS
IF THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE DOING
ME A FAVOR I JUST LEADING ME
THERE ALONE. IN THE PARK THERE
WERE AND HOW THAT TREND THAT
WOULD LOOK AFTER ME. BUT WHEN
OTHER PEOPLE COME DOCTOR
THROUGH IT OR OTHER ASSISTANCE
I WOULD PUT MY HANDS IN FEAR.
IT WAS ONLY AFTER I BECAME
INCREDIBLY SICK AND FINALLY
ACCEPTED SERVICES THAT I WAS
ABLE TO REACH THE- MY ANTI
PSYCHOTIC MEDICINE AND I WAS
ABLE TO BEGIN THE PROCESS OF
PUTTING MY LIFE BACK TOGETHER.
NOW YEARS LATER I LIVE IN
PERMANENT HOUSING AND I WORK TO
HELP OTHER WOMEN OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS. AND PUT THEM ON
THEIR PATH TOWARDS PERSONAL
ABILITY. TODAY THERE ARE OVER A
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN. IN
HOMELESSNESS WITHOUT CHILDREN
OR OTHER DEPENDENTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND EVEN AS THE TOTAL
NUMBER WOMEN CORRAN HOUSE
RINGING TO FLAT MORE AND MORE
WOMEN ARE FALLING INTO
HOMELESSNESS BY THEMSELVES. SB
SIX SEVENTY EIGHT WILL MAKE
CALIFORNIA THE VERY FIRST STATE
DESIGNATE UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN
AS UNIQUE ALMOST POP
SUBPOPULATION. AND TO RECOGNIZE
THEY HAVE UNIQUE NEEDS AND
CHALLENGES THAT MUST BE CLEARLY
ADDRESS. WITH YOUR SUPPORT WE
CAN MAKE CALIFORNIA A NATIONAL
LEADER IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
WOMEN TOLD. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I HOPE THE U. BOAT
YEAH IN FAVOR SB SIX SEVEN
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
PREFER MOVING I JUST WANNA
REMIND THAT WE WANT TO LIMIT AT
TWO THREE MINUTES EACH FOR EACH
THE WITNESS AND WILL BE MOVING
ON TO LEAD. SUPPORT NUMBER TWO.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR RUBIO FOR OPPOSING
THIS BILL TO LIST OF LYFT OF
UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR MY NAME IS
SOPHIA HURRAH. I AM THE
DIRECTOR RESEARCH PLANNING A
POLICY AT THE HAVE PROVEN
INITIATIVES AND THE DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE FOR URBAN
INITIATIVES AT FULLER
THEOLOGICAL SEMINARY THROUGH
THE HARTFORD OF AN INITIATIVE.
THAT WE HAVE PROVIDED
CONSULTING SERVICES THURMOND
JURISDICTION IN THAILAND
CALIFORNIA AND ITS CENTER
CALIFORNIA I THINKING AND
PLANNING AND POLICY
IMPLEMENTATION AROUND
HOMELESSNESS. AND ALSO I HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN IMPLEMENTING
THE HOMELESS COUNT AND SURVEY
TO HAVE EXAMINED DATA TRENDS.
FOR UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN OVER
TIME. I ON A COMPANY WOMEN.
HOME AT THE TOP. LOOKS THE-
LONG OVERDUE. DURING THE PART
OF THE LAST DECADE
UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN COMPRISED
ONE EMPLOYER DOGS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS BUT TODAY
APPROXIMATELY ONE IN THREE
ADULTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS NATIONALLY AND IN
SEVERAL JURISDICTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA HE'S ON A COMPANY
MOMENT. RECOGNIZING
UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN AT THE TOP
OF THE NATION'S FINANCIAL IN
THE EFFORTS TO END AND PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS. I SUCCESSFUL
STRATEGY APPLIED BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION TO DECREASE THE
NUMBERS COME ON A HOUSE THAT
ORANGE WASHED TO PRECISELY
IDENTIFY THEM AT THE SPECIFIC
SUBPOPULATIONS WOULDN'T THINK
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED BUT PART
OF. THE SERVICES AND CARE THAT
THEY NEED. IN PENSION AND THE
HAS. IN A FEW PERCENT DECREASE
NATIONALLY IN BETTER INCOME. BY
CALLING OUT UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN
CALIFORNIA HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO UNDERSCORE THE ABSOLUTE NEED
FOR TRAUMA INFORMED DEFINING
CARE IN ENGAGEMENT SEPARATE
SERVICE DELIVERY IN HOUSING
PROGRAM SERVING AT A COMPANY
NAY MAY NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
RANGE OF THEIR TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCES WHILE LIVING ON THE
STREETS PARTICULARLY
VICTIMIZATION IN THE FALL. AND
THE IMPACT OF THOSEDRAMATIC
EXPERIENCES IN WOMEN'S LIVES
WHEN WOMEN DO NOT FEEL SAFE
THEY DO NOT TRUST INSTITUTION
THE BALANCE FROM ONE SERVICE
AGENCIES MY MOTHER IT WILL NOT
PROVIDE ACCURATE INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR NEEDS A PERSONAL
STORY WHICH IS CRITICAL FOR
MAKING THAT INFORMED DECISION.
LASTLY TO END HOMELESSNESS
AMONG UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN WE
ALSO NEED TO MAKE EVIDENCE
INFORMED DEFICIENCY CONSUMER
IMPLEMENTATION THEREFORE
INCLUDING UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN
AT THE TOP OF THE NATION'S
NEWLY ESTABLISHED HOMELESSNESS
DATA INTEGRATION SYSTEM BY THE
STATE WILL HELP TO. ESTABLISH
INFLOW IN ALCOA PATTERNS IN
HOMELESS AND OTHER SYSTEM
CONSERVANCY DEVELOP A FRAMEWORK
THAT CAN HELP THE STATE
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF WOMEN
STATEWIDE AND BY REGION.
PROVIDE INFORMATION FOR POLICY
AND PLANNING A GENDER LENS AND
A DRUG EQUITY AT THE
INTERSECTION. OF RACE AND
GENDER. MANY WILL ARE DYING
NINETY THREE AND TO MANY OF
TRAUMATIZED OVER IN OVER THERE
ON GOING. ON THE- IT IS PART OF
THE BORDER ARE AROUND
UNACCOMPANIED FIGURATIVELY AND
LITERALLY. I DO HOPE YOU WILL
TO PAY FOR EACH SEVENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE WILL
NOW BE MOVING TO PUBLIC SUPPORT
WILL START FIVE CHECKING AND
ROOM FORTY OF THREE. SEE NON.
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEE NON- WE
ARE MOVING ONTO THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC LINE. I ENDED MODERATED
WE HAVE INDIVIDUALS WANTING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SEVEN EIGHT AND PLEASE PROVIDE
THE TOTAL NUMBER. ACTUALLY I
LIVED IN A JEWISH TO COMMENT
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT
IN A PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE THREE ON THE
LINE- PRESS WE GO TO LINE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ZAKRI WARMER I WITH THE
DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S CENTER THE
SPONSOR OF THIS LEGISLATION-
HARDLY INSIST THE FAVOR- BUT SB
SIX SEVEN EIGHT WISHES TO
THANKS AND RUBIO. THANK YOU.
LIKE TO GO TO LINE SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ANDREW CALLING FROM THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANKS TO THE TIMELINE SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME SEASON COKE WHICH I
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF WOMEN AT
THE INTERSECTION OF
HOMELESSNESS AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB SIX SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU.
AND AT THE TIME THERE NO OTHER
THAN Q. THANK YOU MODERATOR- IF
AT THIS MOMENT CAN YOU PLEASE-
WE'LL BE MOVING FORWARD TO.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. AND WE
WILL FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS
AND HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION AT
THE MALL WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE
HERE DID A TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION BUT WILL BEGIN WITH
PUBLIC COMMENT OPT IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. AND
OPPOSITION. THREE NINE BROUGH
MOVING ONTO ROUTE TWENTY FORTY
THREE NINE. WE'LL BE MOVING ON
TO THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC LINE-
FOR ANY OPPOSITION TO S. B. SIX
SEVEN EIGHT. MODERATOR PLEASE
CONTROVERSIAL WAIT WAIT WAIT TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
SEVEN EIGHT AND PROVIDE THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE. PAGE
NOT ONLY WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT. IT'S ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AT THIS TIME THERE NO
PARTICIPANT IN Q. THANK YOU AT
THIS MOMENT I WILL BRING. BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS. THE
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION. WE HAVE
A MOTION ON SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT
TO US AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. YES THANK YOU TO ALL THE
MEMBERS SO I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK MY CO AUTHOR SENATOR
GOVERNMENTAL TO RUSSELL AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO AND
ALSO THE L. A. COUNTY
DELEGATION FOR THEIR
CONSIDERATION OF POSSIBLY
MAKING THIS A PRIORITY THANK
YOU WITH THAT I ASK YOUR FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. WE HAVE A MOTION
BY CENTER PANEL SB SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT- THANK YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING HER TADO I
FOR TADO I'D JONES JONES III
CORTESE CORTESE II COM WALKER I
AM LONGER BY PAN. CAN I. THE
VOTE IS FIVE ZERO AND THAT BILL
IS OUT. UP NEXT WE HAVE AGENDA
ITEM SEVEN- BY CENTER JONES SB
FIVE EIGHT FOUR PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
MISTER MISTER THANK YOU MA'AM
SURE SB FIVE EIGHTY FOUR OR YOU
WILL REQUIRE RESOURCE FAMILIES
ALSO KNOWN AS FOSTER FAMILIES
TO BE TRAINED. ON HOW TO CARE
FOR FOSTER YOUTH WHO ARE AT
RISK OF EXPERIENCING CHILD
LABOR TRAFFICKING CURRENTLY
RESOURCE FAMILIES ARE REQUIRED
ONLY TO BE TRAINED ON CHILDREN
AT RISK OF SEX TRAFFICKING.
HOWEVER NUMEROUS REPORTS
HIGHLIGHT THAT FOSTER YOUTH ARE
AT A DISPROPORTIONATE RISK OF
CHILD LABOR TRAFFICKING ONE
STUDY FOUND THAT YOUTH WHO HAVE
A HISTORY IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM ACCOUNT 426% OF ALL
YOUTH. WHO HAVE BEEN LABOR
TRAFFICKED FOSTER PARENTS MUST
BE PROVIDED WITH COMPREHENSIVE
TRAINING THAT FOCUSES ON THE
DIVERSE NEEDS OF OUR FOSTER
YOUTH INCLUDING THE PREVENTION
OF CHILD LABOR TRAFFICKING AND
I SHOULD HAVE ONE AND POSSIBLY
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. WE WILL
NOT OPEN IT UP TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF POSITIONALLY
WITNESSES SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WILL BE LIMITED TO THREE
MINUTES. AND WE HERE TO TESTIFY
WE HAVE LEAD SUPPORT NUMBER
ONE. FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PEDRO NAVA THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION AND NEED SUPPORT
NUMBER TWO JAMELIA HINES OF THE
SURVIVOR OF CHILD LABOR
TRAFFICKING. ARE THEY AVAILABLE.
YUP I'M AVAILABLE CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU OKAY. WONDERFUL THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
BOB GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS PEDRO NAVA AND I'M THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE EIGHTY FOUR.
THE COMMISSION IS AN
INDEPENDENT BIPARTISAN
OVERSIGHT AGENCY CHARGED WITH
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE.
TO IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF STATE
GOVERNMENT. LAST YEAR WE ISSUED
A SERIES OF THREE REPORTS
EXAMINING THE STATE'S RESPONSE
TO LABOR TRAFFICKING EVERYTHING
FORM OF MODERN SLAVERY BUT
EXPLOITS INNOCENT WORKERS
THROUGH FORCE FRAUD OR COERCION.
OFTEN VICTIMS ARE TRAPPED IN A
PRESS OF SITUATIONS OUR
DECISION TO FOCUS ON LABOR
TRAFFICKING STEM FROM THE FACT.
THAT EXISTING EFFORTS TO COMBAT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING PRIMARILY
FOCUSED ON SEX TRAFFICKING SO
MANY EXPERTS SUGGEST LABOR
TRAFFICKING IS MORE PREVALENT.
LABOR TRAFFICKING IS A SINISTER
CRIME BUT IT CAN BE DIFFICULT
TO DETECT YOU CAN BE HIDDEN IN
PLAIN SIGHT CLUB AND WITHIN
BUSINESSES OR INDUSTRIES. THAT
MIGHT OTHERWISE BE LEGITIMATE.
TRAFFICKERS PREY ON THE MOST
VULNERABLE AMONG US REGARDLESS
OF GENDER AGE OR CITIZENSHIP
STATUS. AND RESEARCH SUGGESTS
THAT RUNAWAY AND HOMELESS YOUTH
AS WELL AS FOSTER CHILDREN ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO THIS
EXPLOITATION. YEAH CALIFORNIA'S
PROTECTIONS FOR CHILD VICTIMS
OF LABOR TRAFFICKING ARSON. IN
A REPORT ENTITLED LABOR
TRAFFICKING STRATEGIES TO
UNCOVER THIS HIDDEN CRIME. WE
FOUND THAT EXISTING LAWS FOCUS
FAR MORE ON SEX TRAFFICKING.
COMBATING SEX TRAFFICKING IS
ABSOLUTELY VITAL AND MUST
CONTINUE BUT IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT WE TARGET LABOR
TRAFFICKING JUST AS
AGGRESSIVELY. EXISTING
PROTECTIONS FOR CHILD VICTIMS
OF SEX TRAFFICKING PROVIDED
STRONG FOUNDATION UPON WHICH TO
BUILD. IN OUR REPORT WE URGE
LAWMAKERS TO UPDATE THOSE
PROJECTIONS. THAT THEY ALSO
PROTECT CHILDREN WHO ARE
EXPLOITED FOR LABOR. THIS WILL
ENSURE THAT CHILD VICTIMS OF
ALL TYPES OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
ARE PROTECTED UNDER CALIFORNIA
LAW. SB FIVE EIGHTY FOUR WOULD
ADVANCE THE COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATION BY REQUIRING
THAT RESOURCE FAMILY TRAINING
INCLUDE. CHILD LABOR
TRAFFICKING EDUCATION IN
ADDITION TO EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR CHILD SEX
TRAFFICKING EDUCATION. I'LL BE
OUT THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE AND THANK.
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY. THANK WITH A NUMBER
OF. WE WILL BE MOVING ON TO
LEAD SUPPORT NUMBER TWO IF THEY
HAD TO MILLION HINES. ARE YOU
ON THE CALL. OKAY WE WILL BE
MOVING ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE EIGHT FOUR I
WILL BEGIN FORTY TWO OR THREE
SEE NON. ROOM. TWENTY FORTY.
SEVEN NINE ARE WE WILL MOVE ON
TO THE TELEPHONE LINE MODERATOR
PLEASE PUMP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE EIGHT FOUR AND PROVIDE THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY. THANK IMAGE WAS
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE EIGHT CORE. S. ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I THINK SHE MIGHT.
WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON TO JUST A
MOMENT. MODERATELY PUMP THE
INDIVIDUAL PLEASE. HE JUST A
MOMENT GETTING THE LINE NUMBER
FOR LIKE FIFTY ONE I THINK
THEY'RE READY- PLEASE GO AHEAD
NINE FIFTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS THE BALLOT THAT WOULD
TELL THEM WHAT KIND OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MODERATE DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL. A PROPORTION TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT I'M- AT THE
TIME THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN Q.
OKAY HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HER FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. WE DON'T HAVE ANY-
KNOWN WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION BUT WE WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND- I WILL
BEGIN WITH ROOM FORTY TWO ZERO
THREE AND OPPOSITION SCENE
NINE. ONE TWENTY FORTY. SEE
NON. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WHICH HAS FIVE VIA
THE TELEPHONE LINE. AND ONCE
AGAIN PLEASE ABOUT YOUR
CUSTOMER TO NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE BILL OUR
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WE JUST FIND
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE EIGHT
FOUR. PLEASE TELL ME IF YOU
WISH TO DECLINE OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE A FOUR. S. ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MODERATED WE HAVE AN
EIGHT HUNDRED NO OKAY AND-
PARTICIPATING. HELLO THIS IS
ABOUT HELLO HELLO HELLO HI ARE
YOU HERE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE BEFORE.
YES CAN YOU CAN YOU STATE YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION. YES MY
NAME IS EMILY HUYNH AND I AM A
SURVIVOR OF LABOR TRAFFICKING.
AT THE END PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
I KNOW WE ARE MISTER EARLIER
BUT YOU DO YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
TO SPEAK AND- AS A LEAD WITNESS.
AND SUPPORT QUE. R. I'M TWO
MILLION HìNH SURVIVOR OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING I WAS LABOR
TRAFFICKED FROM THE AGE OF
ELEVEN TO THE AGE OF TWENTY TWO
ONE RESCUED I WAS THE FIRST
HUMAN TRAFFICKING VICTIM
IDENTIFIED IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. AND WHEN I WAS SIXTEEN
I TRIED TO REACH OUT TO MY
STATE SENATOR'S OFFICE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO GET HELP
BUT COULDN'T GET NONE BECAUSE
OF THE LACK OF AWARENESS. SO I
HAD TO SUFFER MY TRAFFICKER FOR
SIX MORE YEARS EVEN THOUGH I
HAD CHILD PROTECTIVE SERVICES
AND SOCIAL WORKERS COMING COULD
AT HOME. AND IT WASN'T
RECOGNIZED I WOULD LIKE TO HELP
PREVENT THAT HAPPENING TO OTHER
VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS BY BEING
ABLE TO KEEP TRAINING ON THIS
MATTER SO CLOSE SO WORKERS AND
FOSTER PARENTS. CAN BE BETTER
AWARE OF THESE BIG GUNS AND
BETTER SEE THE RED FLAGS AND
ALSO PROVIDE BETTER SUPPORT FOR
THIS POPULATION. I JUST
RECENTLY DID A TWO HOUR LABOR
TRAFFICKING TRAINING FOR FOSTER
PARENTS IN SOLANO COUNTY. AND
AT THE END OF THE TRAINING.
THEY WERE ASKING FOR MORE
TRAINING. HELLO PLEASE HELP ME
MAKE THAT HAPPEN NOT JUST FOR
THEM BUT FOR OTHER FOSTER
PARENTS AND SOCIAL WORKERS. I
THINK THIS BILL AND PAVE THE
WAY FOR OTHER BILLS TO FURTHER
HELP VICTIMS OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING. SO WE CAN BE SEEN
AND HEARD AND NO LONGER
INVISIBLE. PLEASE HELP ME ET
THESE CHILDREN BACK TO BEING
KIDS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR YOUR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE EIGHT
FOUR FIVE AT AT THIS MOMENT I
REALLY WANT TO BRING B- AT THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. HAVING GONE THROUGH
A BOTH SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION-
GOOD QUESTION FOR CRIMINALS
WILL START WITH SENATOR PATTON.
I THANK YOU AND- WHAT THINK YOU
OF AYE SIR JOHN CENTER JOBS FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I DID
HAVE A BRIEF QUESTION-
CERTAINLY AGREE THAT- WE NEED
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF LABOR
CHECK CHILD TRAFFICKING AND IN
TERMS OF- TRAINING FOR RESOURCE
FAMILIES THE TWELVE CENTS ON
THE BILL TALK ABOUT DURING THE
TWELVE HOURS OF PRE APPROVAL
TRAINING SO. IS THERE SOME
THOUGHT ABOUT DO WE NEED TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF TIME FOR
THE FOR THIS TRAINING IT'S A TO
INCLUDE THIS TRAINING OR DOES
IT DISPLAY SOMETHING ELSE IN
THE TRAINING SO THAT SO
CERTAINLY I AGREE THAT THAT'S
TOPICS IMPORTANT. I'M ALSO AS
AN EDUCATOR JUST CONSCIOUS OF
WHAT WE DISPLACING THEN WITH
THAT OR WE GOING TO BE THINKING
ABOUT ACTUALLY INCREASING THE
AMOUNT I DON'T KNOW OF THAT
TWELVE HOURS IS A CODE OR WHERE
THAT SITS- SO MAYBE THERE'S
SORTS ABILITY BUT. IT AND SO
COULD YOU JUST THAT PLEASE.
SURE AND I AM. A DOG PANTANAL
HAVE LIST. ANSWER FOR YOU TODAY
BUT I WILL- JUST DON'T YOU KNOW
KINDA. LET THE COMMITTEE KNOW
THIS IS KIND OF A FOLLOW UP ON
AREAS ASSEMBLY BILL FROM LAST
YEAR- THAT THIS WAS INTENDED TO
BE A PART OF THAT BILL- SO
WE'RE WORKING WITH HER OFFICE
ON THAT SO BEFORE- ON THIS
WORKING WITH OUR OFFICE ON THIS
ALL BE HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP. AND
GET YOU THAT INFORMATION- AND
FIND OUT OF THAT'S ENCODER FOR
CAN BE EXPANDED OR- WHAT WE
WOULD NEED TO DO TO GO FORWARD
ON THAT. OKAY YEAH I MEAN JUST
JUST BEING CONSCIOUS THE OTHER
CONTENTS OF THAT TRAINING BUT
CERTAINLY THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
MOVE YOUR BILL IS THE PERFECT
TIME. THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY AT
DINNER WITH MISTER MAESTRO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WELL AS
FAR AS A THANK YOU TO THE TWO
WITNESSES THEY DID A GREAT JOB
ESPECIALLY JIM MILLION BAND-
YOU KNOW RESCUED FROM THIS
HORRIBLE CONDITION AND SO- AND
HER DRIVE AND INTENSITY TO
PROTECT OTHER KIDS- FROM THIS
FATE AND SO I'D ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO PLEASE VOTE I
THINK YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR PASSED ON SB
FIVE EIGHT FOUR. AND CONSULTANT
HERE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
FIVE EIGHT FOR THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HER TADO HI
FURTADO I'D JONES. JONES BY
CORTESE RIGHT CORTESE I'D COME
LONGER HI KAMARG OR I'D PAN AM
FIVE THAT'S FIVE ZERO. THE VOTE
WAS FIVE ZERO AND THAT BILL IS
OUT- WE WILL MOVE ON TO A
CONSENT ITEMS. THE MOVED. THE
MOVE BY A SENATOR PAN AND A
CONSULTATIVE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SB ONE HUNDRED BY HER
TADO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SB THREE NINE
THREE BY HER TADO THE MOTION IS
DO YOU PASS. BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SB TWO TWO EIGHT
BY LEYVA THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED BUT FIRST BE RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AND S. B. FOUR SIX ZERO BY PAN.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT
FIRST BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH. HER
TODDLE. TIME FOR TITLE II
JONES. ONES BY CORTESE CORTESE
I COM LONGER HI. MOM MARKER I
PAN NIGHT PAN AYE. AS THE BILL
IS FIVE DURING THOSE BILLS ARE
OUT AND WE WILL BE MOVING ON TO
BILLS THAT ARE ON THE CALL WILL
BEGIN WITH- AGENDA ITEM ONE SB
FOUR THREE FOUR- COMMUTED
CONSULTING YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SB FORTY THREE FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CORTESE. FOR TCI.
THE BILL IS FIVE ZERO AND THAT
BILL IS OUT. UP NEXT AGENDA
ITEM TO SB SEVEN SIX EIGHT BY
SENATOR GLAZERS CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB SEVEN
SIX EIGHT THE MOTION IS DO YOU
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CORTESE BY. PATES THE AYE PAN
NIGHT AND I. THAT'S FIVE ZERO.
THE BILL IS FIVE ZERO AND THAT
BILL IS OUT. BOB I HAVE AGENDA
ITEM S. SIX SB FOUR SIX FOUR
CONTROL TO KEEP PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SB FOUR SIX FOR THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS JONES. JONES NO
THAT'S FOUR TO ONE. THE BILL IS
FOR ONE AND THAT BILL IS OUT.
CONTROL TO DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL BILLS ON CALL NO
OKAY. SO THANK YOU ARE TO ALL
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
AND WRITING TO THE SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR-TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THE SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE AS A DRIVER.